[Music]
hey i'm vanessa welcome back to tasting
our roots we're gonna be hanging out
with chef jj johnson from minton's
restaurant in harlem i'm so anxious to
meet him because he is such an
inspiration to young chefs everywhere
and we're going to learn about his food
we're going to learn about feijoada
imagine adding spice to black beans rich
meats adding some fresh flavors on top
of that like orange fresh cream tomatoes
so these aren't basic black beans these
are not basic black beans
at all these are like beyonce and black
beans i'm kind of shocked that you would
have a side dish be beyonce
ah don't do that to her
you did that to her oh my gosh oh my god
she's never going to talk to me now chef
jj thank you so much for joining us
today oh thank you for having me how
does it feel to be working in a space
with such a historical significance this
space is where bebop was found this
space is where a lot of our famous jazz
musicians were found before mentions was
just like this jazz club where people
would go eat at the season and come
after and the people were coming in here
like oh wow who's billy holliday who's
miles davis who are these people what's
his music they're playing they're
playing bebop my great-grandfather used
to play in a jazz band with a lot of
famous musicians and i know that he used
to play at minton so tell us about the
dish we are making today so just we're
making today's feijoada we give you like
a big piece of oxel meat some lamb
sausage and then we do like an orange
pico de gallo if you really like deep
into it they call like the food of the
slaves because at that time you just had
beans rice and then all these forced
meats but it really stems from portugal
brazil this is amazing i have to have it
so i'm ready to get in the kitchen i'm
gonna teach you a quick trick when you
cook
beans don't salt them and if you add
lemon it keeps its color so i said how
can i create my own path when i went to
ghana i started smelling these dishes
and seeing these dishes that my
grandmother cooked that's when i knew i
was gonna be a chef that was my
lightbulb moment we'll throw in some
shallots now you need to build flavor on
top of flavor on top of flavor like that
my pet peeve is when i see chefs go into
a space and they just adapt to the
environment when that's not even who
they are yeah like i'm the food of the
african diaspora that's who i am that's
my makeup that's my dna that's what
makes me the chef in the kitchen that i
am or when i'm cooking this is the base
of how the fedjuarda gets started we're
throwing some lamborghes
merguez is a north african sausage
so there's cumin there's paprika there's
coriander seeds so my dad's
african-american my mom is puerto rican
invasion so my grandfather's from
barbados my grandmother's from puerto
rico but i grew up like in this super
cultural household and food was in my
dna it's just who i am like cecil opened
up in 2013 nobody was talking about the
food of african diaspora they were
talking about southern food or soul food
but nobody was like really going deep
i'm cooking the food before and where it
traveled and how it got there and where
those people are really researching
those things so are we just heating up
the sausage and now we're gonna cook the
sausage through we're gonna get those
rendered down like really nice we're
throwing some collard greens
i have a huge chef crush on chef jj he's
young he's charismatic he's so
unapologetic and he pushes himself and
challenges every dish he makes all right
we're gonna do some
a little bit like crispy collards
so two pieces of some nice cut octal
it's like a nice little orange pico de
gallo
and that's my fuzzy wow and we just
built that like ground up ground up
you going to the corner no i want to get
a little bit of everything i don't
actually know if that's possible you can
do it okay i'm just going to eat it like
this this is so good
[Music]
how spicy if this dish were a celebrity
it would definitely be rihanna she's
tender and she's got a little heat and
then like she then once in a while
she'll surprise you like something sweet
like it was unexpected but then it all
works together this is what your dishes
are about this sums up who you are in
your food to me and i appreciate you
sharing some really insightful things
that i think i'll be able to take and
that a lot of other people will be able
to take as well i love this so that's it
here at minton's with chef jj and our
harlem adventure join us next time in
our new city on tasting our roots
you